au plus fort de l'activité on arrive
jusqu'à douze mille têtes de bétail qui
était présente ici des boeufs des
moutons et des dévots essentiellement il
faut imaginer il y a deux cents ans sur
l'actuelle place de la république à côté
de l'hôtel de ville à poissy l'un des
principaux marchés aux bestiaux de paris
à l'occasion de l'exposition et des 200
ans de la halle du marché nous avons
fait installer des bâches qui reprennent
les principales oeuvres artistiques qui
sont présentés dans l'exposition
puisqu'un peu plus loin à la maison de
faire de poissy bestiaux la foire
retrace l'évolution du marché aux
bestiaux de la commune le marché un
marché ait connu depuis mille ans à peu
près testé depuis mille ans qui
s'appelait la foire à l'époque mais
c'est sous sa loïc en fait
l'autorisation a été donnée par le roi
de commerce des têtes de bétail donc on
peut parler de 800 ans de marché aux
bestiaux sur la ville de poissy après
l'ouverture de la halle en 1822 le
marché va tripler il va atteindre sa
taille maximale en 1867 avec 2,5 ha fois
ci se trouve en fait à
la jonction en fait plusieurs voies
routières se situe le long de la seine à
un positionnement géographique
particulièrement intéressant car il ya
un pont qui enjambe d'une des premières
maisons de la région parisienne et en
fait été beaucoup plus facile pour ceux
qui arrivaient par voie navigable de
s'arrêter impossible au port de poissy
et de traversée par la route toutes les
merdes qui mène au coeur de la ville de
paris dans cette exposition des tableaux
des dessins caricatures mais aussi des
plans d'archivés municipales sont
présentés l'occasion de valoriser le
patrimoine l'histoire de la ville et sa
toponymie cette carte qui date d'avant
la révolution
quelle occasion de voir comment tous les
troupeaux arrivait en fait par toutes
les portes de la ville
donc cette porte de paris existe encore
une part de l'apport de la tournelle ici
on a le pont qui traverse la scène à
partir de 1844 un concours de boeufs
gras est organisée il sera à l'origine
du salon de l'agriculture inauguré en
1964 l'exposition est visible jusqu'au 6
novembre